season seven i can't believe it's at
this point
it's incredible how quickly time flies
brother versus brother
i mean to be able to create new episodes
for your fans that must mean a lot to
you
oh and this is one of the most fun shows
too brother versus brother
it's that ultimate twin sibling rivalry
experience
and we actually had shot 99.9
of the show before covent hit and so
really it was just you know a very
little bit that was left to finish it
off but we um we're excited because this
is one of those shows that all year
round people
they're asking us when is the next
brother yeah we shot it here in la
and it's the house next door and a house
will block up
and so these are expensive homes these
are the most expensive homes we've ever
had on brother versus brother
um but it's it takes it to a more epic
level and the
the rewards and punishments for the
winning brother losing brother
it takes it to a whole new level as well
i think think superhero
i think action superstar i think
hollywood vancouver i know i saw the uh
the trailer
and i think you're like bond in a lambo
and you're like tom cruise days of
thunder
on a motorcycle i mean this is what it's
all about the impact of it
what is some of the punishments uh so
we don't want to give away too much
because that's always one of the nice
surprises that we do but
um one for example um the losing brother
so there's the
la brea tar pits in in la pretty much
the losing brother had to go
into the tar pits and collect the
garbage out of them while the
uh the losing brother did that while the
winning brother got to go and actually
explore
foxholes and yeah excavate uh i will
tell you this much as well with the
whole hollywood theme
there is the the company that makes the
superhero
outfits for all marvel movies there's a
little something happening with that
the winning brother just saying are you
guys fans of marvel
the news about chadwick boseman it's
absolutely crushing um you know we
didn't know him personally however
a lot of our friends did and just you
know he was
not only an amazing actor and an
incredibly nice person but really
i think he did something with with some
of these films that he had just put out
that
really inspired people to really move
people yeah i met him briefly at the nba
all-star celebrity game
um he had just come to watch and and
support and he's just such a
down-to-earth person and supportive
person and
that he was battling cancer for four
years it's really sad
but all our love is with the family yeah
yeah
it is all about family because your
brother's part of this as well
and he's playing the referee so who does
he like best
i think i'm his favorite yeah it's more
because i have linda on my side
that's why i'm judy's favorite jd
definitely spends 90
of his time just trying to wade through
all the bs that comes out of drew's
mouth
how's the saying go the kettle calling
the window black
i don't know the drew is always so
confident about every single challenge
and
if he loses a challenge it's always like
what there's no possible how ever like
are you talking about this no possible
way there's never any problems i like to
get under jonathan's skin by really
playing up whether i'm winning or losing
i'll just play it up
uh but he does weird things too one day
we found him hiding in the pantry to see
if he could
overhear jd and me talking about what
i'm doing on my project oh and i heard
things
uh also yeah i mean i don't want to give
away until you watch
but uh i mean the whole thing is it's in
my neighborhood i know the area
right and also it keeps jonathan nice
and close so i can spy on
this sounds like survivor all over again
there was one uh
guy who was on it who would do all this
stuff where you'd hide and listen to
conversations
uh and also the hetv there's gonna be
some stars that are actually gonna be
voting on who wins so who can we expect
yeah uh again i don't live every little
secret but
uh i will tell you jasmine roth who is
an amazing amazing
uh contractor designer she's gonna be
coming to judge
uh brig and jane as well
mccormick yeah and so a little brady
reunion
but um but yeah i mean the the great
thing with the show too
is as you know every episode is a
different area of the home so we bring
different judges in
and i just love these houses they're
historic homes
and so these are beautiful we have to
cherish the the history of these homes
but they're not functional in any way so
we have to add a lot of modern
functionality to it
you're going to love it yeah was there a
lot of rules i'm just realizing i don't
know if you brought us to talk about
the premier brother versus brother on
september 13th or to explain how to hang
the pictures on the wall behind you
i'm noticing that you've got pictures
that aren't hung on the wall and one's
falling flat and
is that why you actually brought us here
can you not see the back
i just noticed my pillow's there i have
it's a disaster
you know what this is what it's all
about though okay you guys you guys need
to come and fix my house but this is
you know right now there's so many
lessons in life right now what home
means right and you have new episodes of
for
forever home as well i mean being
through isolation and through this
pandemic
what is forever home now is it redefined
for you
it you know it really is for for
everybody because we're all spending
more time at home and
especially with families where you have
you have kids you know you're on top of
each other so
people you know in their forever home
we've always renovated to customize it
to what their needs are but now they're
realizing more needs
separate rooms they need to find ways to
be together but also
have space apart cut yourself in concept
for
isolation the uh no i it is true
multiple purpose spaces are very
multi-purpose spaces are very important
right now
and i think something else that we're
realizing because people are messaging
us
on mass are just simple solutions for
storage because you've got
stuff all over and people's work space
is now at home and it's just a hazard
one of the great things is that you guys
to celebrity iou and i have to say kudos
to you for such an incredible show
uh did any of the celebrities connect
with you after it
aired or after shooting like you know
brad pitt oh yeah
everybody connected after the show and
uh just said
uh actually after the show um we have
even
seen uh you know some of the challenges
as well or i know drew for example
has been zooming with uh michael buble
and whatnot
i just give him vocal lessons you know
it's important for me to share my
wealth of knowledge but we uh you know a
little uh sneak peek nobody
else knows this yet but we're gonna tell
you we have started shooting season two
i'm not telling you anymore i'm not
gonna tell you who's in it but all you
need to know is
your mind is gonna be blown when you see
who's the part of season two
i wanna give me a hint all right
it's not saying either
but i would love to come on set and see
you guys do your magic i mean i'm just
inviting myself and kind of
seeing what you guys do okay i'm coming
all right all right
it's such a great show we're filming in
australia right now we'll see you there
okay perfect how long is the play well i
can't get out of play but
you know there's so much you guys are
doing right now at home with linda and
drew your your podcast
speaks on so many levels especially at a
time like this and when you have guests
that are on and talking about their home
is there something new that you've
learned yeah i mean i think a
really cool thing for at home is linda
and i you know we just love having real
conversations with amazing inspiring
people and
we're finding more and more we're really
digging into what life is all about
for all these different guests it's not
just talking about sort of that surface
level fluff
it is really digging into what's
important to them uh what their
their interests are and also too when
we're talking about when we had
conversations on race and we had those
experts come in and talk about racial
literacy
it's really important for us to educate
our listeners and our viewers through
us learning so i love that i'm i'm all
for the shallow stuff
yeah and you're celebrating your first
anniversary with zoe is that right that
just happened in april i think
and there was a beautiful video i mean
she rocks
you looked out buddy man she's pretty
awesome i'm dating up
she's great i gotta i gotta up my game
pull up my socks
does she like renovation now does she
like to do construction is she into your
world
nope she so we uh she's got a good
design
yeah design yes construction no like the
the the dirty loud all of that stuff
yeah i don't like that either yeah
she's admitted that that's just not her
jam but she
loves design and so um you know she
watches
those shows she reads magazines she's
always like pulling together
inspiration boards of her own
i love that you know you two are so down
to earth every time i see you guys you
have this beautiful positive energy
and a time like this where you get to be
almost still even though you're working
so many hours you get a chance to be
still
what was a priority for you before
that's not a priority as much
now i you know i i think
especially when i was single i didn't
care about
like flying around all the time and we
when we looked at our schedule
we were flying about 350 hours a year
in order to do all the stuff that we
were doing we run our company and the
products in addition to the shows
and it's just not of any interest now i
want to i want to help families we've
helped over 400 families with property
brothers and forever home
that's amazing and i love that we've
done that but i think we can do that
but not have to travel so much i think a
lot of um
corporations are going to learn that uh
from this whole pandemic in isolation
that
there are new ways that they can operate
that are sort of leaner and meaner they
don't have to spend as much
on traveling around which is also
something that's going to have a
positive impact on the environment